and Trump says the current impeachment
inquiry against him is putting future
presidents at risk and he's acquainting
the process to a crime from one of the
most infamous chapters of American
history chief White House correspondent
John Roberts is here with details long
john reckon evening to you president
Trump and his Republican colleagues
found themselves in a familiar position
today President Trump under fire for
what was criticized as a racially
insensitive tweet Republicans having to
choose between standing behind the
president or running for the hills
president Trump kicked off the day
igniting outrage tweeting about
impeachment all Republicans must
remember what they are witnessing here a
lynching the comparison to lynching drew
immediate condemnation across the board
from Democrats Illinois congressman
Bobby Rush tweeting you think this
impeachment is a lynching what the hell
is wrong with you do you know how many
people who look like me have been
lynched since the inception of this
country by people who look like you
ruch supports impeaching the president
as does Texas Democratic congresswoman
Veronica Escobar
an incredible disrespect to the country
is what what he did this morning with
that comment it was awful it was awful
on the Republican side reaction ranged
from full support for the president this
is a lynching and every sense this is an
American to a more nuanced reaction
there's no question that the impeachment
process it's the closest thing of a
political death row trial so I get his
absolute rejection of the process I
wouldn't use the word lynching but
Republican congressman Adam Kinzinger a
trump supporter who also frequently
disagrees with him called the president
out today tweeting never should we use
terms like lynching here the painful
scourge in our history has no comparison
to politics and President Trump should
retract this immediately a new CNN poll
out today found support for impeachment
at an all-time high for their survey 50%
of respondents now saying President
Trump should be impeached and removed
from office however among Republicans
only six percent now support impeachment
down from 14% in a Sept
Kember survey democrats appear to be
slowing down the process the initial
target to complete the impeachment
inquiry was Thanksgiving but with only
twenty days left on the house calendar
and Democrats planning high-profile
public hearings to gin up support for
impeachment the schedule could slip all
the way to the Christmas break on
Hannity last night president Trump
complaining Republicans haven't been as
tough as Democrats I think the
Republicans should get tougher if they
stick together I respect that the other
thing is they're vicious they're much
more vicious we would never do a thing
like this if the house does approve
articles of impeachment said at Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell today said he
will be ready I have no idea how long
this will go on what I can tell you for
sure is if the house impeaches we will
be on it it will displace everything
else and we'll be on it until we finish
and adjust the last minute Brett a
statement from the press secretary
Stephane Grisham about ambassador
William Taylor's testimony today the
deposition that he gave in Congress
Stephane Grisham saying quote president
Trump has done nothing wrong this is a
coordinated smear campaign from far left
lawmakers and radical unelected
bureaucrats waging war on the
Constitution there was no quid pro quo
today was just more triple hearsay and
selective leaks from the Democrats
politically motivated closed-door
secretive hearings every day this
nonsense continues more taxpayer time
and money is wasted President Trump is
leading the way for the American people
by delivering a safer stronger and more
secure country that do-nothing Democrats
should consider doing the same Brett
John Roberts live on the North Lawn John
thank you now more anonymous chart